hey everyone welcome back i'm richie and
this is part two of i played every call
of duty game in 2021 so if you want to
watch part 1 the link for that will be
in the description below
last time we ended things with call of
duty world at war which means modern
warfare 2 is next so buckle up drop a
like look out for spoilers and i hope
you enjoy
[Music]
i cannot tell you how many times i
watched this trailer i showed it to
anyone who would listen i remember
showing it to my sister someone who
hadn't touched a video game since 1996.
the hype i had for this game was simply
unreal and when i finally got it i went
straight to work
needless to say i was excited to boot
this up again and play through the
campaign that i hold near and dear to my
heart
truthfully i was ready to remove the
rose tinted glasses and experience this
story as honestly as i could which was a
hard ask because the nostalgia is very
real when it comes to this game going
back to 2009 all of my friends were back
online and we'd play this game for hours
every night and when they weren't around
i was playing spec ops and trying to
beat the campaign on veteran mode to get
every xbox achievement i could
even then i remember thinking that this
was one of the best video game sequels
through and through and i haven't even
talked about the game's story yet after
the events of modern warfare 1 where you
kill imran zakayev a new russian ultra
nationalist rises to power vladimir
makarov
following zakaev's footsteps makarov is
a cunning terrifying villain who wants
to take america down and will ignite a
third world war to do it in the early
hours of the game he frames the us for
one of the biggest massacres ever
from that point he becomes your entire
world you spend the entire story in his
shadow always one step behind
sounds like a wild goose chase but it's
an intense one filled with false leads
nuclear deterrence and a major betrayal
you know the one
throw in the plots of red dawn and the
rock mixed with an incredibly dramatic
ending and you have yourself modern
warfare 2.
ugh honestly i'm just flustered thinking
of what to talk about next the
multiplayer and how broken the guns were
or how we went from three kill streaks
to 15 including a nuke how about how
good it felt to see price again and how
badass it felt to break him out of the
gulag oh or how cool it was to play
alongside soap and his little mohawk or
what about when the white house needs
saving and your whole squad gets emp'd
in the process every mission and nearly
every moment matters in this game it's
truly over the top in every conceivable
way if i keep talking about it i'll pass
out so let's move on
it was at this point in time where the
idea of the call of duty cycle felt
comfortable to me one year we'd get an
infinity ward game and the next year
we'd see what treyarch was up to while i
was always looking forward to whatever
modern warfare had planned it was nice
to have something else to play as i
waited only this time for me it felt
like treyarch's newest game was in
direct competition with the modern
warfare series call of duty black ops
was launched in late 2010 and while i
remember being excited for a new cod i
wasn't exactly sure what to expect this
time
treyarch had finally ditched the world
war ii titles not for a modern setting
but rather the 60s the cold war is in
full swing and bad ass characters like
woods and mason are introduced to keep
the war from going hot
treyarch definitely had fun when it came
to the story and especially how to tell
it this was a whodunit mystery full of
paranoia secrets unreliable narrators
which was all massively different from
modern warfare's action movie take as
soon as the game starts you find
yourself brainwashed and tied to a chair
a mysterious figure from behind glass is
yelling at you about the numbers and you
and your character mason have no idea
what the [ __ ] he's talking about it's a
disorienting and memorable intro
followed by a fun and flashy campaign as
the story progresses it does a good job
of unraveling the plot without giving
everything away all at once this makes
for a cinematic ending where you finally
figure out what happened to alex mason
and what those goddamn numbers mean
aside from the plot the gameplay is
solid you have a cool choice of weapons
that are fun and powerful while they're
not as fast and broken as modern warfare
2s they hold their own in campaign in
multiplayer black ops also introduced
some awesome spy weapons and gear like
the ballistic knife and crossbow perfect
for the kinds of missions the campaign
throws at you speaking of the missions
your black ops team is tight it's
usually just you woods sometimes bowman
and reznov whose involvement in the
black ops series is way less
straightforward than before that's
because there is no resnoff
well there is and then there isn't it's
a little messy but if you've seen fight
club it's almost the same logic
it's a roller coaster of a story and
lives up to the hype even in 2021
it kicked off its own grand story arc
into the call of duty universe and at
the same time expanded the zombies
narrative it also had
awesome multiplayer
so while i was still waiting for modern
warfare 3 i was all in on what black ops
had to offer
speaking of modern warfare 3
in 2011 when i picked up modern warfare
3 it was hard to accept that this might
have been the last modern warfare game
there could never be a call of duty 4
modern warfare 4 though i knew i had to
make this one count and of course it's
awesome even today
in modern warfare 2 we left off with
soap on the brink of death after a stab
wound from stupid shepherd
i know a place where the only words i
had to hold on to hoping the story would
pick up right after this very moment
while you get a glimpse of their
whereabouts in the intro instead you're
treated to black tuesday as the first
mission
an introduction to world war 3 in new
york city you play as frost an army
ranger who needs to stop a massive
russian signal jammer from the stock
exchange
starting up this campaign i remember
looking up and feeling dwarfed by the
environment for the first time in a call
of duty game and how creepy it felt to
simulate warfare on city streets i had
walked on before but also i couldn't
help but notice how cool my m4 sounded
and how vibrant the game looked and oh
hello hybrid site looking good
two minutes in and i was already
invested but while i patiently played
this first level i couldn't help but
wonder where's makarov are soap and
price safe what color is my underwear
my patience paid off with the very next
mission we learned that soap and price
are not okay and that they're now the
two most wanted men in the world after
killing shepherd when the world thought
he was a hero
you spend the campaign not only evading
all of russia but traversing the rest of
the world to try to corner makarov
along the way paris falls to a massive
chemical attack the russian president's
daughter is kidnapped you're running
away from sandstorms
and of course
he kills soap
he's gone
one of the harshest memories across all
games in the series something i didn't
think infinity ward would have the guts
to do
they killed soap
from there i realized two things one
modern warfare's main storyline was
coming to a close and two the ending of
this game was gonna be unforgettable i
knew captain price would do what he had
to do to stop makarov because he [ __ ]
up and made it personal
boy was i right
the final mission where you track down
makarov is yet another highlight moment
in the series
price and yuri are equipped with
juggernaut suits and they make their way
to the top of a fancy high-rise hotel
where makarov is hiding i remember after
hearing price say
i gripped my controller and prepared for
the end
it was like a chapter in my adolescence
was coming to a close this is something
i and millions of others put our hearts
into for four years so to say the ending
was bittersweet only scratches the
surface from 2011 to 2012 i spent most
of my gaming hours grinding in the
multiplayer and for the first time i
reached max prestige but it was a weird
time for me where i dropped out of
college worked part-time at another
crappy job and wasn't sure what to do
next while i was figuring things out
modern warfare was a great distraction
so it wasn't all that bad
before i knew it things were back on
track and another call of duty was
coming out
none of this surprises me as far as
campaigns go the announcement of black
ops 2 was the first time i wasn't
excited to jump right into the story
starting with modern warfare 2 i would
always try to play out the story lines
first then jump into the multiplayer
after i felt familiar with the game's
environments characters and weapons but
the gritty orange future tense plot
simply didn't interest me so that year i
didn't play it and instead jumped right
into multiplayer with everyone else
when i finally did start the story for
the purposes of this video i was nervous
but ready i really enjoyed multiplayer
and zombies how bad could this campaign
really be the first few missions are a
smooth transition from the first game
you play as mason now in the 1980s and
your first order of business is to find
frank woods who was presumed dead after
black ops 1
but new intel from laos says otherwise i
enjoyed these missions but as i feared
the jump into the future missions had me
less enthralled you now play as alex
mason's son david your job in these
future missions is to put a stop to an
organization of revolutionists led by
raul menendez
menendez has had beef with america his
whole life the cia killed his parents
and years later you catch him working
for kravchenko as a gun runner
this story spans decades and is played
out by you back and forth from past to
future you're put on the spot to make
choices that branch into multiple
endings
some make you feel like you screwed up
and others feel just about right there
are even some mixed endings with a
little bit of both what the [ __ ] but
while experiencing all of this in my
first playthrough i guess the problem
was that i didn't care about the
future's problems we go from woods and
mason tag teaming like the old times to
hearing tony todd from candyman call
everyone a [ __ ] we finally got one
over on this [ __ ]
squeezing russia's balls
[Music]
i felt disconnected from the plot every
time i jumped back into the future
by the end these future missions get a
little better but i always just wanted
to get back to the 80s with woods hudson
mason
not
session what the [ __ ]
visually the game also took a toll on my
eyes in some parts character models
repeat a lot and i wasn't trying to
notice this but it just kept happening
it was distracting hey
quit eyeballing the chicks we got to get
our asses in gear let's move
some things i did appreciate were the
multiple story endings the silly rock
band ending with avenged sevenfold and
the voice acting
alright let's go [ __ ]
most of the cast returns except for
hudson was actually played by michael
keaton now he's headed to the house
we'll get him but we do it as a team in
the end i enjoyed my time with black ops
2 but i think the campaign is
overshadowed by the excellent
multiplayer and zombies mode so while
it's not my favorite i'll always have
fond memories with it
[Applause]
oh boy here we go next up i'll be
discussing the handful of exclusive
titles for the nintendo ds
i'll be talking about these in a group
since they share the same fundamental
features like gameplay graphics and
storytelling elements ok
to start i want to mention that these
were a lot of people's first ever call
of duty games looking at the nostalgic
comments on these gameplay videos
honestly makes me smile
not everyone had access to the mainline
m rated console titles like i did so for
a lot of people it was these games or
nothing at all there are many crappy
games that hold a place in my heart as a
kid i didn't always have the latest
consoles or games so i kind of just
played whatever i had over and over that
meant mastering even the shittiest of
games just to see what the end would
look like or in a lot of cases the next
level
i feel like this might be the experience
for kids who played these ds games
nostalgic if flawed the same could be
said about the call of duty games on wii
and i can personally speak to that i
have a younger cousin who loved world at
war and when i tried showing it to him
on the xbox 360 he just wanted to play
the wii version instead
let's dig in the controls are a headache
obviously there are a limited number of
buttons on the ds but i feel like the
layout could have been utilized much
better using the d-pad controls your
horizontal movements while the screen
and stylus function as a mousewood
sounds pretty innovative on paper but in
practice it really isn't the games
themselves are not as bad as i thought
they're all spin-offs of their console
counterparts some of them have familiar
characters sprinkled in but most of them
are side stories set in the same
universe
but given the platform it's surprising
what they were able to pull off
there are recognizable weapons music
tracks and a light sense of familiarity
with the environments the voice acting
is charmingly bad i don't know if it's
the mixing but everyone just sounds like
a teenager
you're the demolitions expert so clear
this area of any explosives more and
more of these titles were released and
they didn't change very much if you're a
call of duty superfan and are curious
maybe play one of these games but these
are hard to recommend to anyone else
anymore as for me i don't think i'll be
going back to these my hand still hurts
call of duty declassified on ps vita was
a surprise to me this game was poorly
reviewed critics said it was way too
short glitchy and downright appalling
and made no waves in the gaming space
and was written off as a throwaway title
the story takes place between black ops
1 and 2. you play as either frank woods
alex mason or a cia agent in a series of
mini missions usually gathering intel
saving someone or killing someone
unfortunately complaints about the
game's story length are valid each
mission can be completed in 5 minutes or
less and you can beat the entire game in
less than an hour playing it for the
first time in 2021 i bought a used copy
for about 12 bucks but i think i'd be
pretty mad if i had to pay the full
price of 49.99 it's simply not worth it
but for 12 bucks i wasn't mad at all did
you enjoy black ops 1 and 2 and want to
squeeze a little more juice out of the
story here you go and yes the missions
are short so i'd recommend the veteran
difficulty for a fuller or at least
longer lasting experience
but if we put the issue of story time
aside there's fun to be had here it ties
into black ops in some fun ways i didn't
expect
earlier when i was talking about black
ops 2 i said the cia killed raul
menendez's father well you actually get
to play out that mission as a cia agent
you watch as a teenage rival menendez
gets away
and while it's a little weird it was
cool to use guns from both black ops and
modern warfare 3. it also looks sounds
and runs well because the ps vita is
awesome if you're at all interested i
think you should try this for yourself
it's short but there's some meat on
these bones and even an active
multiplayer i'm also going to quickly
mention the nokia n-gage version i won't
be playing it because it's more of a
collector's item nowadays it was a cell
phone portable gaming console hybrid and
it had a port of call of duty on it i
did play it in high school and it sucked
the screen is small and there are a lot
better games for that system so i'll
show you some footage here but i will
not be playing it this time around sorry
[Applause]
every time i think about call of duty
ghosts i think about infinity ward and
how hard it had to be to follow up the
modern warfare series and i think this
is the best they could do remember
earlier when i said how players were
sick of world war ii games and how that
led to the era of modern shooters well
this marks the point where those players
started to get sick of modern shooters
infinity ward was in a pickle on top of
that it was just hard to accept that the
modern warfare series had come to a
close i remember somberly tuning into e3
that year to see what infinity ward
could possibly do next the stage show
wasn't bad but i just wasn't hyped i
couldn't even force it they talked about
riley the dog too much and i knew i
wouldn't have the fullest experience if
i wasn't playing on next-gen hardware
which surprise i had no money for
plus despite what i thought this game
was called ghosts but it wasn't about
ghost i mean i knew he was gone but i
was puzzled
november came and i scrounged up just
enough money to buy the 360 version it
was the first time i bought a game with
the second install disc which somehow
felt embarrassing it's like if xbox said
here you go broke ass i also went into
this game alone by this time in 2013 my
old xbox and cod friends weren't playing
so much anymore regardless of everything
trying to stop me from playing this i
popped it in and went straight to
multiplayer which left me
unimpressed
for the first time i felt like not
enough had been done to prevent it from
feeling like a copy and paste experience
i watched as the youtubers i followed
tried to keep up but their excitement
was gone and it was contagious
months later i remembered that i hadn't
tried the story mode yet and i'm glad i
remembered because the campaign is a
whole other experience as you start the
game you learn about the legendary
ghosts an elite team of soldiers who
took out their enemies 300 style
outnumbered but tactful
while these tales are harrowing they're
more of a myth with no proof they even
exist
after you learn of the ghosts from your
character's dad elias the game's story
picks up in modern day san diego which
has fallen to an attack from an orbital
kinetic strike basically space lasers
ten years after the attack logan and his
brother hesh team up with their father
elias and other members of the military
to defend what's left of the west coast
when things get serious their dad elias
stops playing and reveals that he is in
fact a leader of the legendary ghosts i
had a hunch he was a ghost but you know
i let the story do its thing for the
rest of the campaign the team is on the
hunt for rourke a brainwashed ghost who
works for the bad guys called drumroll
please
[Music]
the federation
once they capture rorke the ending is a
bleak relief for these two who
essentially saved the us from another
strike from the federation and just when
you think it's over the game leaves you
on a cliffhanger moment when war comes
back and drags logan away to an unknown
location
years later people were anticipating a
sequel to ghosts but it never happened
next time we'd hear from infinity ward
they had plans for infinite warfare
instead
in fact the next game wasn't going to be
developed by infinity ward or treyarch
that's where call of duty advanced
warfare comes in
as soon as i heard that the next cod was
taking place exclusively in the future i
was pretty bummed the trailer for
advanced warfare didn't pump me up and
the thought of jumping around with exo
packs in multiplayer was the nail in the
coffin
it felt weird i normally at least tried
to give every yearly call of duty a shot
at least for the story but this was a
weird time where the stars just didn't
align for me i still didn't have the
newest console i was back in college and
broke and call of duty in the future was
the last thing on my mind
the series was also in a weird place
with fans both sick of historical and
modern settings which didn't leave a
clear place for the series to go except
the future so when i picked up the game
about a year later i went in kind of
numb but ready to be proven wrong at the
very least i could see the infamous
press f to pay respects scene that
moment happens about 20 minutes into the
game shortly after the first mission you
play as private jack mitchell and in the
opening scene jack and his best friend
and fellow marine will irons are in
south korea helping to push an attack
from the north just as they're about to
complete their mission will's arm gets
caught on a mobile missile launcher and
just before he can disarm it it blows up
will is gone and jack is left with only
one arm after the infamous funeral scene
will's father jonathan irons gives
mitchell his card and tells him that his
private military company atlas could use
a guy like him it's a terrible plug for
his business at his son's funeral but
it's a great indicator of his character
and an introduction to his company atlas
of course jonathan irons is a power
hungry [ __ ] who wants nothing short
of world dominance and will use atlas to
achieve it it's actually a fun plot that
could really be its own movie the
gameplay felt smooth and the new gadgets
are fun to try out when traditional
running and gunning fails one of the
standout memories of my playthrough
includes the sound design i can't
describe it other than crunchy it's
really satisfying
the nice soundwork also carries over to
the suits firing weapons and the
crumbling environment around you the
cinematic cutscenes are beautiful with
voice acting and mocap by kevin spacey
and troy baker whose performances were
all top notch there weren't as many
standout moments like in other cod games
but as a whole i enjoyed the story and
the performances in some ways it didn't
feel like a call of duty game at all and
that's sort of the theme for the next
few titles
i paid no mind to black ops 3 upon
release i was close to graduating and
when i heard they were going to continue
with a futuristic direction i was ready
to quietly dismiss a whole another year
of cod plus i still hadn't played part
2's storyline turns out i didn't need to
black ops 3 was very loosely based on
the events after black ops 2 taking
place in the 2060s and featuring another
mind-bending plot that involved ai mind
control and existing in a simulation
to say that i was worried about starting
this game is quite an understatement i
didn't only pass up this campaign until
now i avoided it but considering how
much i enjoyed advanced warfare i went
in with a clear head hopeful that this
game could change my mind
you play as
player and in the very dark opening
mission you and your pal hendrix need to
rescue the egyptian prime minister saeed
instead what ends up happening is you
get your arms ripped off oh my god why
on the brink of death income stabler
from law order svu to save you you wake
up on the train with stapler whose
actual name is taylor sitting right in
front of you but only in your mind this
is where you're introduced to the direct
neural interface or dni for short it's
basically an implant that allows
communication between other dna users
only in your mind conscious or not
right away taylor and the black ops team
recruit you and drop you into training
simulations based on failed missions
from the past the controls are
unsurprisingly smooth and the futuristic
environments are nicely realized things
like wall running and double jumping
work well within these set pieces and
nothing was really hard to learn
the story that i was so scared to face
also turned out to be not that bad or
even that complicated
basically taylor's black ops group are
the good guys but they have to pull off
some bad things for the greater good big
picture stuff in between missions
there's a hub that i didn't really care
for you can show off your collectibles
read mission logs and wonder who the
hell these random people are it kind of
slowed down the pace for me because
they're unskippable you can also
customize your loadouts here which again
i didn't care for
call of duty's in the past have always
set you up with a pretty good default
loadout and left you room to explore
other weapons simply by picking them up
off the ground
but here you can't even do that what you
pick is what you're stuck with what the
hell oh my god
as you progress you start to hear
whispers of a frozen forest a seemingly
metaphoric place where everything is
okay in short it exists and it was
designed by a man named yusuf saleem but
taylor and his black ops team are
obsessed with finding this forest and
will do anything to get into it why
because the black ops team is infected
with a dni virus called corvus they
think the source of the corvus virus can
be found within this frozen forest and
if they can get there they'll be able to
purge it from all of their systems it's
a little confusing for a call of duty
game but it makes for some fun moments
in storytelling when you finally reach
the frozen force and purge the corvus
virus you come to and taylor's voice is
still in your head
so basically player and tailor
successfully purge the virus but
player's mind is sort of taken over by
taylor what's your name soldier
in a frozen forest i said what's your
name
taylor
so taylor might not be the best of guys
anyway i applaud this game's risks the
creative ending made it worth playing at
least once i still wouldn't call it a
very approachable call of duty but give
it a shot if you want something a little
off the beaten path
after merging with neversoft studios the
updated infinity war team envisioned an
all-new story set primarily in space and
since me and space still weren't getting
along i skipped call of duty this year
too but again i went into this with a
fresh perspective reminding myself that
i've been surprised by more than one
call of duty campaign before so i jumped
in and hoped that infinity ward would
not let me down
this game had some major advancements in
the series like seamless transitions
from ground to air nearly non-existent
loading times and a hub world straight
out of battlestar galactica it doesn't
feel like call of duty but i'm here for
it in the game's opening mission the
good guys are sent to secure some top
secret weapons when they're stopped by
the bad dudes and admiral koch the most
vapid villain in any call of duty game
which sucks because he's kit from game
of thrones isn't he i think he's just
written really poorly i hated seeing
this guy anyway after this first mission
goes sideways we meet lieutenant nick
reyes and nora salter in these opening
hours i was happy to witness some solid
writing except for koch
excellent motion capture and a really
polished presentation there's plenty of
military speak that goes in one ear and
out the other but the performances and
relationships kept me engaged from the
start
speaking of relationships after the
introduction we meet ethan he's a
lovable robot who's ready to serve his
military
it's hard for some people to trust him
at first being a robot and all but his
friendly nature and quick wit win over
even the toughest of soldiers
the navy's official policy for a
gunfight
in the marine
there are some fun standout missions
including dog fights in space and
fighting terrifying evil robots who have
been programmed to kill you all
accompanied by your buds ethan and
salter by the way reyes and salter come
on secret space romance
everyone else aboard the retribution
space station is important and memorable
at first they just feel like a crew but
as you see them with more frequency you
build relationships and trade stories
soon enough the crew feels more like a
family i think infinity ward felt this
way too because the ending credits paid
tribute to just about everyone you get
to hear them talk candidly about their
lives and experiences and sort of a dear
john style message they individually
record including ethan who sadly
sacrifices himself for reyes overall i
enjoyed the campaign way more than i
thought i would there were some pacing
issues and some strange character
development choices but the gameplay was
solid and the relationships you make
were simply delightful that's the last
time i let a call of duty set in space
stop me from giving it a shot
this was one of the biggest surprises of
the bunch 2017 was an important time for
me in call of duty history i started my
job at gamespot but i hadn't played a
call of duty game in years however when
i heard that this next title was boots
on the ground i told myself i was in no
matter what fortunately for me it was
world war ii developed by sledgehammer
games now i say fortunately because i
love this game but when i say that i get
some funny looks and i get it the series
was pushing further into the future that
meant exo suits cool tech flashy space
weapons and a blank canvas to create any
story they wanted a world war ii game
just felt like the opposite of that idea
taking several steps back in the eyes of
most fans under normal circumstances i
wouldn't want to play another world war
2 game either but the stars aligned for
me on this one and i was willing to give
anything that wasn't in space a shot
welcome to the bloody first
you're a long way from texas farm boy
world war ii was the refresh i needed i
spent hours in multiplayer so much so
that i never got around to the campaign
i was addicted to the prestige grind and
earning supply drops to get the newest
weapon skins i played war mode for hours
sweating it out to make the push deep
into enemy territory only to get pushed
back into my own i kept putting off the
campaign until now and i'm sad i did
because the story is just as good
right away you're treated to a quaint
and ominous opening aboard the ship with
your fellow soldiers i'm bad with names
so i feared i'd forget everyone's name
here entirely fortunately the game does
not allow this this is your crew the
soldiers you fight alongside with
throughout the entire campaign even josh
dumel who's a dick
as the division makes the push on to
normandy i felt like i was watching a
movie about it the pre-rendered
cutscenes are stunning not only that but
the dialogue and nervous banter are all
believably written in this vulnerable
opening i felt my stomach curl i felt
like it was taking forever to unload
onto the beach but when it happened i
still wasn't ready it was after this
emotional retelling of d-day that you
feel relieved to see some of your fellow
soldiers that made it it's here
afterwards where you can take a moment
to control and establish the systems and
mechanics that this game has there's no
regenerating health you can call on your
squad mates for scouting grenades health
packs and even artillery strikes on
veteran difficulty utilizing your
soldiers like this is a must it was
something new to me but useful in the
majority of the campaign
speaking of the campaign this is a
massive departure from the first three
call of duty games its presentation is
beautiful everything from the sound
design and writing to the score and set
pieces this game is a real treat to the
eyes and ears any drawbacks i had were
from the repetitive nature of some of
the tougher levels and again i think
that's only because i was playing on the
veteran difficulty but it's a call of
duty game after all and there are some
off-the-wall missions like the train or
escaping the clock tower but they're few
and far in between there was also an
espionage mission i wasn't expecting it
plays just like the one in black ops
cold war where you can control what's
being said and even blow your cover in
the end i'm so glad i gave this game a
shot back in 2017 and even happier to
report that i love the campaign i
accidentally skipped over and even josh
dumel i guess he's not a dick
before i move on this is a quick
reminder that black ops 4 didn't
actually have a story mode outside of
the training missions there were some
things here and there but they were
weird like mason's granddaughter and
woods being an item
that's why i love you sweetheart make no
[ __ ] sense whatsoever
anyway treyarch was reportedly very
rushed with this release and instead
focused on everything that wasn't a
campaign that gave us tons of zombies
maps multiplayer and of course blackout
i only have a few memories with blackout
but i honestly wasn't into the battle
royale scene not yet at least i think i
want to give it another chance but
that's a video for another time moving
on
[Music]
2019 was a big year for call of duty
modern warfare was back with a soft
reboot rooted in ultra realism the
campaign's tone was much darker dealing
with the war on bioweaponry and nuclear
warfare those things aren't new to call
of duty per se but if we strip away the
high octane dramatics of the original
series you get this muted realistic
story that couldn't have come at a
better time it was perfect for someone
like me who loved modern warfare because
i got to watch the series mature and
grow into this awesomely realized and
updated story
after a chemical attack on london
captain price is brought on to find and
capture the wolf a terrorist leader who
takes responsibility for the attacks
along the way he teams up with gaz
pharah alex and others to cover the
globe to put a stop to these attacks the
casting for these characters is superb
especially for captain price i love this
interview with infinity wards taylor
kurosaki and barry sloan about the
audition process and how picking barry
sloane to play captain price was a
no-brainer he was perfect for the role
as you make your way through the story
you find yourself in several intense
situations memorable missions like the
piccadilly circus and clean house force
you to act and react in some dramatic
no-win situations there are also a lot
of less is more instances for example
the mission clean house only has like 11
enemies but as a whole this game is very
memorable and replayable the strong
characters realistic settings and story
accomplished what they set out to do
bring back the modern warfare series and
live up to the legacy it set more than a
decade prior modern warfare 19 was a
massive success so much so that i don't
even think they knew what they had this
game made such an impact and while it
got the yearly cycle of support from
infinity ward and activision fans like
me were sad to see that support fade
away in order for them to move on to
other projects
now of course this happens what are you
new it's activision it's the way they've
done business for years but this felt
special fans agreed that a whole another
year of modern warfare support could
have worked but we'll never truly know
well at least there's always modern
warfare 2019 part 2.
until then i can't say enough good
things about this game it was the most
excited i've been to play a call of duty
in years and of course warzone was an
extension of this using the same game
engine weapons and maps it was another
attempt at a battle royale an attempt
that exploded
millions of players cod fans are not
swarmed to warzone and helped it become
one of the biggest free to play games
ever
even after the constant issues with
download sizes weapon balancing hacker
accounts it's still a massive success
one that supports cross-console and
cross-gen it also extended the warzone
story admittedly it was nothing
groundbreaking but hey if you offer me
more modern warfare i will take it
if modern warfare 2019 was the steaming
hot cup of coffee then black ops cold
war was the cool cup of sweet tea to
calm me down
seeing this cool 80s marketing and
trailers got me pretty pumped and that
was because at the time of this
announcement i still hadn't played black
ops 2 or 3. so seeing familiar faces
like woods mason and hudson and no sign
of the future was cool and that's what
this game is cool it takes elements from
the first game like brainwashing and
espionage and gives it a fun 80s kick
with more vibrancy and even humor
not a [ __ ] word down while we go back
to the faster paced arcade style of
gameplay it totally works for this game
you're bell a cia operative trying to
take down perseus a soviet rebel who
hates america and wants to nuke it into
the ground you don't have much to go on
as perseus works in the shadows all you
have are some shaky leads and this one
[ __ ] picture that burns into your
retinas you and your team sneak around
europe in search of clues and leads and
of course you're always two steps behind
it's not all bad though missions always
keep you on your toes and there's plenty
of misdirection intense moments and
decisions to be made
missions with woods and mason are also a
real treat there are even some callbacks
to the first black ops game like the
snow base and of course the numbers
program
working alongside adler it's fun too
he's as smooth as the other guys
smoother if you count the sunglasses
like seriously he never takes them off
not even in the espionage mission
elevator conversation always gets
awkward he's a walking man of mystery
and while he's easy to work with
trusting him is another story the truth
is he can't trust you either
it turns out your character belle has
been brainwashed by adler and the cia
essentially to help them out like a
puppet you can help adler and stop
perseus and his massive nuclear launch
or say and let america burn and kill
everyone woods mason adler everyone
playing through this was weird but it's
technically not canon it's a fun
approach to wield this much power and
shift the game's ending entirely both
endings are good and worth exploring as
none of them truly interfere with the
original black ops series they've
extended this story into multiplayer and
warzone but naturally the pacing is a
lot slower because it's seasonal based
but cold war as a standalone title is a
fun neon step back into the 80s with
familiar faces and an engaging story
especially for classic black ops fans
if you've made it to this point in the
video i can't thank you enough
call of duty has obviously been a huge
part of my life for the last 15 years or
so and there are so many creative people
to thank for these games and the
memories that go with them but i also
did want to thank you guys for watching
because this took a lot of time writing
production and i don't do this to hear
myself talk i do this to share stories
with you guys so if you have call of
duty stories of your own let me know
down in the comments like this video if
you like this video and i'll see you
next time